VAIBHAV SINGH: Hello, everyone.
My name is Vaibhav Singh.
I'm a machine
learning specialist
working with Google Cloud.
And here is--
TAYLAN BILAL: I'm Taylan Bilal.
I'm a software engineer in
Google Cloud working on PyTorch
on TPUs.
VAIBHAV SINGH: And
today we're going
to talk about PyTorch
at scale on cloud TPUs.
So let's get started.
And here is going to be
our map for the talk.
We're going to start
with an introduction.
Then we'll move to a
step-by-step walkthrough
of an example.
We will discuss how
it exactly works,
and how to scale your PyTorch
training on Cloud TPUs.
And finally, we are going to
leave you with resources, tips,
and tricks so that you can
start to train your PyTorch
model on TPUs today.
PyTorch is officially
supported on Cloud TPUs.
This support is made possible
through the Torch XLA
library, an open
source initiative
from Facebook and Google.
It was announced in October
2019 at PyTorch DevCon
and has been growing ever since.
The support reached beta
with PyTorch 1.5 release
and would be generally
available by the time you'll
be seeing this recording.
For those of you who are
not very familiar with TPUs,
TPUs, or Tensor Processing
Unit, is a hardware accelerator
built by Google in
2015, first to address
its own internal needs.
The very first
generation of TPUs
was an inference-only chip.
Beginning with
version 2, it evolved
to support training as well.
And beginning with
version 2, Google also
made TPUs available to
the rest of the world
through Google Cloud,
with the vision
to help push machine learning
state of the art forward.
You can scale your
machine learning workloads
using TPUs from eight cores
all the way to TPU pods.
TPU pods consist of
thousands of TPU cores.
As you can see on the
left-hand side of your screen,
TPU comes in two
different flavors
on Google Cloud as of today.
That is TPU v2 and v3
You can start with
a device, as you
can see on the left-hand top
corner of your screen, all
the way to the full pod.
Our Cloud TPU v2 pod
comes with 512 cores,
and our Cloud TPU v3 pod
comes the 2,048 cores.
You can choose a slice
of a pod, all the way
to the full pod for your
machine learning trainings.
Here is a Cloud TPU device.
In order to access
this device, a user
creates a VM, or a Virtual
Machine, on Google Cloud
and creates an
instance of Cloud TPU.
You can create this instance
in different device types.
In this case, we are
choosing v3-8 That
indicates a v3 device.
Each v3-8 comes with four chips.
Each of these chips has got two
cores, and each of these cores
come equipped with
matrix multiplication
units, two matrix
multiplication units each,
and 16 GB of high
bandwidth memory per core.
All in all, this device
has got eight cores,
and that's why when you
choose the accelerator
type when you are
creating this device,
you choose v3-8 or v2-8.
Whereas when you're working with
pod, in case of a Cloud TPU v3,
a full TPU pod consists of 256
TPU devices, or 2,048 cores,
interconnected with the
high speed interconnect,
which lets the
gradient averaging,
or all-reduce operation,
run very efficiently
on the full pod.
The TPU software stack enables
you to train all the way
from a TPU device to the TPU
pod or any intermediate size
without any code changes.
And it always acts
as a single node
without any complicated
cluster setup.
Now let's take a look into
an example of a PyTorch code
as we know it, and then see how
this code needs to be modified
or what other
modifications we typically
see in order to run that
PyTorch code on Cloud TPUs.
So first of all, let's begin
with a familiar territory.
For those of you who are
familiar with distributed
training on PyTorch,
you have already
seen similar examples, similar
elements such as the PyTorch
distributed libraries.
You see the model, you see
the model being transferred
to the devices, in
this case GPU devices,
you see the familiar
elements like DataLoader
and DistributedSampler.
The DistributedSampler
makes sure that each
of the replicas of
the model are actually
looking at the different
slices of the data,
not looking at the same slice.
You see familiar elements
like the train DataLoader.
You see the forward pass
within the training loop
and the backward pass,
which computes the gradient.
You see the Optimizer step.
That is going to
update the parameter
based on the computed gradient
and the Optimizer of choice.
And you notice the
Torch multiprocessing
spawn method, which
executes this training loop.
In this particular example,
four different replicas
of this model are
running in parallel.
Now let's see how
this code changes
when we are going to train
it on Cloud TPU device.
As I was describing,
a Cloud TPU device
consists of four Cloud TPU
chips on eight TPU cores.
Beginning with the elements
like Torch XLA library,
this is what makes the training
of PyTorch model on TPU
possible.
Similar to what you
saw in case of GPU, now
we have another device
abstraction called XLA device.
This is an abstraction
of Cloud TPU core.
Similar to how you were
transferring your model
on Cloud TPU device, you
are transferring your model
on Cloud TPU core here.
And finally, the elements
like the DistributedSampler
or the DataLoader remain exactly
the same with one difference,
that we are using a
parallel loader, which
is a wrapper, here that makes
sure that the data upload
operations to TPUs are run in
parallel with the computations
in order to make the
data pipeline efficient.
One more important
distinction to highlight here
is that we are using
the Optimizer step
method from XLA module instead
of optimizer.step method
that you saw in the
previous example.
This is to make sure that
the all-reduce operation is
performed first before the
optimizer.step is called
to update the parameters.
And finally, instead of the
Torch multiprocessing module,
you have XLA
multiprocessing module,
which has the similar spawn
method, which under the hood
takes care of all the
necessary TPU device
initialization and setup before
using the Torch multiprocessing
module to start again
in a similar fashion.
The process is
running in parallel
to facilitate the training
on eight different replica
of your model in
this case, because we
are running on eight cores.
And also notice the start
method equal to fork,
which is used to make sure
that the model is copied
into the memory only once.
Each of the child
process will be
able to use all the resources
that spun up before that
in the global scope.
Now let's look at a live
example of one of the trainings
that we are going to do
on ResNet-18 model using
the CIFAR10 data set.
So I start with
the Cloud console.
Here I have set up a
Cloud AtPlatform notebook
instance with
PyTorch XLA library
and all the necessary
components ready to go.
So I start my notebook instance.
In the meantime, notice also
that I have created a Cloud TPU
instance.
That's a v3-8 device.
So four chips, eight cores.
Notice the runtime
version that is
displayed in this column
whenever you create a Cloud TPU
device.
And this is the
internal IP that is
used to set up xrt_tpu
config environment variable.
Before you start
the training, this
is required for the
user VM or your VM
to be able to communicate
to the TPU instance.
So we're about to demo
the PyTorch ResNet-18
model on CIFAR10 data set.
So as described
earlier, we start
by setting the xrt_tpu
config environment variable.
This is the IP address
that we noted earlier.
So we execute this cell.
Then define some
hyperparameters.
Then sourcing the
libraries there.
Notice that here we
are using the ResNet-18
model from TorchVision library.
Then we define
our training loop.
Notice in the training loop that
apart from the training loop
function, that we have seen
in example walkthrough there,
we also have the test
loop function defined
for our tracking the evaluation
metric and the results.
Rest of the aspect
of the code should
look very familiar to you
based on the walkthrough.
Here is the helper function
for plotting the results.
And this is the
function that is going
to call the training
method, which
will have the training loop
function that we saw above.
We're using the XLA
multiprocessing spawn method
here.
And we are using the mp
function as one of the argument
and passing the other flags
specifying the number of cores.
And start method fork, as
described in the walkthrough.
And then here we start.
So as this training
is starting to run,
we're going to look
at another instance
of this notebook, which
has this whole training
execution finished.
And as you would
notice that we execute
this training for 20 pods.
That is going to take a
few minutes to finish.
After 20 pods, it attains
close to 78%, 79% of accuracy.
And you can also notice that
it is possible to track things
like images per second
and other metrics
as you would do in a
normal PyTorch code.
So here we are getting
almost 76% of the accuracy.
And then here, we are ready
to visualize the results.
And these are the results here.
And you can see that,
for most of the examples,
it was still working well.
And there are some
error cases as well,
since it only attained
about 76% of accuracy.
Now that you're familiar
with Torch XLA usage,
you may be wondering
how exactly it works.
If you're familiar with
PyTorch tensor class or ATen,
you already know that it extends
support to multiple device
implementations or memory layout
through dynamic dispatches
to those implementations.
Torch XLA extends ATen
with a new type of tensor
called XLA tensor.
XLA tensor is different from
other eager implementations
in that it's a lazy tensor.
While eager tensors are
dispatched op by op,
and the only computation
graph that is generated
is for the gradient
computation, and as soon
as the gradient computation
or the backward pass is done,
this graph is destroyed,
in case of lazy tensor,
PyTorch XLA just constructs an
XLA intermediate representation
graph with no
evaluation is performed
on this graph until required,
either by a certain operation
in your model code
itself, or by a call that
necessitate the context transfer
from the tensor to scalar.
Building this IR graph also
enables PyTorch XLA to do
certain graph-level
optimizations,
which are not
possible if you are
doing the op by op dispatch.
This IR graph is then
compiled and sent
to TPU device for execution.
Between training steps, if
the IR graphs are identical,
XLA compilation
is not performed.
However, if IR graph is going
to change too frequently
between training step or because
of the nature of the code
itself, every time it
changes, the XLA compilation
needs to be performed.
And it might slow
down your training.
To take more details into what
are the things to watch out for
and how you can make the most
of your PyTorch training,
here is my colleague
Taylan, who will
talk about tips and tricks.
TAYLAN BILAL: All right.
Thanks Vaibhav.
So let me talk about some
of the tips and tricks,
things to watch out for when you
port your model from GPU code
to TPU code.
One of the most common pitfalls
is dynamic input shapes.
As Vaibhav noted
earlier, every time
the intermediate
representation graph changes,
this triggers an
XLA recompilation,
and that slows things down.
And this happens when the model
has input shapes that change
from one step to another.
A good example is
an NLP model where
you have sentences of
varying length, for example,
or an image model with
images changing shapes.
Another common pitfall
is what we call a context
change between device to CPU.
And the most common occurrence
for that is when the code has
tensor .item calls in it.
This slows things down
because, as Vaibhav
noted earlier, XLA is built
on a lazy tensor idea,
and the item calls
prematurely causes evaluation,
and the result is
suboptimal if that happens.
Third most common pitfall
is if the model code
is using some operation that
has no XLA implementation yet.
Then that doesn't
cause an error,
but it causes the
IR graph to get cut,
and the operation that's
not lowered to XLA
gets executed on the CPU,
which slows things down.
We want to stay in the device
context as much as possible.
When that happens, these things
happen, we have solutions.
For example, for the first
problem, dynamic input shapes,
we may use padding.
We may take the sentences
with varying length
and pad it to a fixed length.
Or maybe we predetermine
three or four fixed lengths
and pad it to the next length.
And in the latter case, we
will still have recompilations,
because the input
shapes will take
three or four different values.
And the first time they are
seen, we're going to compile.
But we're going to
waste less FLOPs
as a result of less padding.
So there is a trade-off there.
Second, when we have the tensor
to scalar context change,
or device to CPU
context change, this
can happen because of, for
example, loss reporting,
because loss is
usually a tensor.
What we do, we recommend
to reduce the item calls,
and report loss every n steps
instead of maybe every step.
n can take a value
of 20, 30, 100.
That's up to the user.
The user could also
have item calls
from another part of the model.
They need to be
spotted and eliminated.
In the third case, if we
encounter an op with no XLA
lowering, we usually just
create a GitHub issue
in github.com/pytorch/xla and
ask the Torch XLA team to lower
the said op so that the
operation runs on the device
and is accelerated as a result.
We have talked about
problems and solutions,
but how do you actually
understand what is going on
and what the
problem actually is?
So this is the
slide from earlier.
We want to focus on the
white rectangles here.
We are importing Torch
XLA debug metrics here.
And we are printing
the metrics report.
This metrics report contains a
lot of information about what's
going on at the XLA level.
And it can surface
some of the issues
that I just discussed
in the previous slides.
And let's look at an
example metrics report.
This is just a summary
that focuses on the issues
that we discussed.
The actual metrics report
contains more information
than just this.
If you look at the first
part, the metric compile time,
this gives us information about
how many graph recompilations
have occurred in this workload.
And in this case, we have 202
compilations that occurred.
And the total time
it took is 6 minutes.
Now the metrics
report is usually
composed of metrics
and the counters.
The counters give
information about what's
happening in the code.
For example, the
Counter MarkStep
tells you how many training
steps that we have taken.
For example, in this case,
232 steps have been taken.
And that resulted
in 202 compilations,
which suggests that there
is a problem with the graphs
that the code is generating.
The compilation should be low.
Some compilations
initially are OK,
but it shouldn't grow as
the number of steps grow.
Similarly, for example,
in the item call problem,
the context switch
between device and CPU,
the counter ATen
local_scalar_dense
will be your friend.
And here in this case, you
have 240 occurrences of that.
And that's something
that needs to be reduced
to get optimal performance.
In the third problem
that we discussed,
the op that's not
been lowered yet,
you will see an ATen counter
with the op's actual name.
And in this case, we
have 232, probably once
per step, some op that
needs to be lowered in XLA.
And once you iron
those issues out,
the code will run much faster
and will be very performance.
Now so far, we have
seen how training
works on a Cloud TPU device.
Now let's discuss how to
take it to the next level
and train on a Cloud TPU pod.
As pods were described
by Vaibhav earlier,
they consist of several
devices connected
with very fast network.
And in the PyTorch
XLA context, we
create as many user VMs as the
Cloud TPU devices, not cores.
So for example, if you want
to train on a v3-32, 32 cores,
we would need to create four
VMs to drive the training.
And we wrap these user
VMs in an instance group.
So everything needs to
be in an instance group.
And once we have set
up these resources,
launching the training
distributed mode is very easy.
Now let's look at the
command to do that.
Here, the white part
of the large command
is the actual
command that you were
running to run on one device.
So this is your
code with arguments.
And all you need to do to
scale it up to a pod level
is just prefix the command
with these elements.
And here, the green
part is xla_dist.
It's offered by Torch XLA.
And it coordinates
the resources,
sets up the mesh between the
instance group and the TPUs,
and sets up the environment
variables specified
by the next set of elements.
For example, the TPU name,
the conda environment,
and any other
environment variable
that you might want to set up.
And that's it.
There's really no code changes.
One gotcha here
is the code needs
to be written so
that the data is
charted across all the cores.
Otherwise the VMs will end
up doing the same work,
unnecessary work.
But that's really
the only gotcha,
and scaling up is as easy as
just prefixing your command.
So now let's look at some of
the models that actually have
been tested and known to work.
In the computer
vision area, we have
ResNet and ResNeXt, along
with most TorchVision
models such as MobileNet and
others that already work.
In the NLP area, we have
transformers that work.
For example, FairSeq's
Transformer, RoBERTa,
or HuggingFace's Transformers.
We have a working implementation
of a deep convolutional again.
That's up on our GitHub.
And in the speech
recognition world,
we have worked with FairSeq's
Wave2Vec and vector quantized
Wave2Vec.
Let me note here that the
models that work on Torch XLA
aren't limited to these.
These have been
tested, but people
have run other workloads
and other models
successfully as well.
And you can port
your model as well.
To get started, here
are some resources.
So these are some of the
tutorials that are offered
on Google Cloud web pages.
And it covers some of the
models that I just discussed
in the previous slide.
And along with the
Google Cloud tutorials,
there are Kaggle kernels from
some of the Kaggle experts
in the community.
They have successfully run
competitions on Torch XLA,
and they offer their
kernels to the users.
And finally, here is a summary
slide of all the resources
that we saw.
Some of the GitHub
repositories that
are relevant to the project,
official tutorials, Kaggle
kernels.
And please visit PyTorch XLA.
It's a very active open source
library, and open issues
if you encounter any
issues, et cetera.
Thanks for listening.